- Hi, I'm Sal Khan, founder
of the Khan Academy.
I just wanted to let you know
about our India talent search.
As you might know, Khan Academy,
we're a not-for-profit with a mission
of providing a free, world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And to us that means that if
you are a villager someplace
and you don't have access
to a formal school,
then you might be able to
access a low-cost smart phone,
and then be able to self-educate yourself
and one day prove what you know,
so that you could get a job,
or go into higher education.
But ideally, you're using Khan Academy
in conjunction with a classroom.
Where the classroom can
allow students to learn
and work at their own pace,
give data to teachers,
free up class time for
more open-ended projects
or peer-to-peer learning
or Socratic dialog.
So we have a call out for the talent,
the teaching talent in
India to work with us.
By being part of this talent search,
for one, you'll get a chance
to practice making videos yourself,
and we're looking for folks
in math and science initially,
but eventually all subjects.
It's a way for us to find talent.
Talent that can help us create content
that will educate tens of millions
of learners throughout India.
So the opportunity here is,
I think, pretty exciting.
There will be prizes,
but maybe the biggest prize of all
is the opportunity to contribute
and help to your fellow citizens.
If you want to participate,
participate by December 12th.
And now, I'm going to
hand it off to Aanand,
who is our head of content in India.
- I had a great math
teacher where I grew up,
and I used to keep wondering,
what would it be like if way more students
could learn from someone like him?
And also got me thinking,
how many other such great teachers exist
whom I'm not able to learn from,
just because they're not able to teach me?
So I know that as a teacher,
what's the biggest dream?
It's to be able to reach as
many learners as possible.
And in India that could
be tens of millions,
maybe hundreds of millions
of learners who could
learn greatly from us.
So it's been a dream to
conduct a talent search
which would bring together
these great content creators
and create content for math and science,
and maybe many more subjects.
So this year, we're finally able to do it,
and in this talent search
we're looking for math and science
to begin with, for standards six to 12.
In English and Hindi, again to begin with,
and who knows, next year we might do
a much larger project than this.
So send your entries.
Here's Grant who won last
year's U.S. talent search
and who's currently a
fellow, to say a few words.
- Hey everyone, my name
is Grant Sanderson.
I had the good fortune of last year being
one of the United States
talent search winners.
After that there was a kind of
a whirlwind of experiences.
I ended up being a content fellow here.
I've been working on
multivariable calc content
and a little bit in other math areas.
Probably this goes without saying,
but one of the biggest benefits
of being here is the reach.
And I mean the global reach.
Knowing that the stuff
that you're going to make
actually influences a lot
of students lives out there.
For example, in India, I'm really excited
that they're doing an India talent search
for India-specific content.
Because this means people
can create math content,
or whatever else, much
better than I ever could,
or much better than anyone here ever could
just because it is
localized in that sense.
So I'm excited to see
what you have to make
and have fun.
- One thing to keep in mind
when you make your submissions
is we care a lot more about the content
and the substance of your video
than the production value.
You should also let everyone you know,
know about this talent search.
I'm sure you might know some
really good teachers out there.
And try to get your submissions
in by December 12th.